elaborate on that a little bit right
it's almost a kind of the Amazon
approach of hey let's deliver as much
back to the user or customer as possible
and then they'll stay with us for a long
period of time obviously a lot of your
competitors are charging higher fees and
and that kind of extracting more value
why did you choose to go with the low
fee model and they kind of how is that
thought process changed over time sure I
think um there's a number of factors
there's a mentality factor of the
different founders how much do they
believe in this industry whether they're
short term a long term and then there's
the skill that we already have or people
already have so to be honest when we
first start that the goal is just to
survive right so just to get to cash
flow breakeven and be able to survive
and potentially if we're not there yet
then we may want to investors take a
little bit of a risk and then also get
gets rewarded later on so initially if
that's my thought process and once you
go over that heard always like well now
the mentality really comes into play
it's quite to be honest once you have a
like a reasonable exchange running you
have like decent number of users etc
it's not that hard to make some money I
mean yeah you will be able to it make
some money but then most platforms or
most businesses the more you charge that
the slower you grow and the the more you
charge you may even you may even like I
should actually have a short-term
business the uncertainty in this in this
industry also causes people to be more
short-sighted for example if you
establish an exchange in a country and
the regulations change every three
months then you are kind of forced to be
more short-sighted and just sort of look
let's let's make as much money as we can
as quickly as possible and then when
things change which is pack up well or
at least we cover our investments but I
think I've always I've been in the in
the industry for a long time even before
by that so I have a much longer term
play I believe quickly it will be they
won't be the super future like if you
look at 10 20 50 years a hundred years
from now so I have a much longer vision
on this and luckily we got over the bump
for the sort of cast
survival mode very quickly like within a
few months and it was also within those
first few months like even with the
first quarter after we launched the
transform we seemed like some of the
regulations change in China that
impacted us quite severely but actually
afterwards looking back it was actually
a very positive influence we actually
drove a lot of users to us but at the
time it was like quite tricky so we we
got we've gone through the initial sort
of phases very quickly and right now we
have a platform that's the half scale
and we have we have the brand and I
think what I think right now we have a
much longer I have a much longer term
sort of play I just want to be able to
service users for the next 20 50 100
years hopefully so yeah so for us it's
really not about making soap making all
the money right now so businesses very
often have to have to decide between
short-term profits versus long-term
gains for us everything from for us
everything's long-term so this is why
we're still investing in large company
in large deals in this environment it's
not about the next three months it's not
about the next year it felt like more
than that so and also we're not a
publicly listed company so we don't have
this sort of Wall Street analyst calls
etc we do have a token by the tokens
getting more and more district to
centralized and tokens to be fine but so
I think so I think basically we are we
have a testament have a key aspect of
this is really important so for this
reason we we really want to protect our
users we review our users much much more
than our short-term revenue so we do
make money we make money very
transparently people so that's pretty
much it really yeah yeah you mentioned a
public company any interest in ever
going public or your do you enjoy being
a private company with without all of
the these short-term pressures yeah so I
don't I I don't think we're going public
anytime soon we're not preparing for it
we're not prepared for it so we're kind
of running the company you know in
direction that's not really fit for
appeal so a lot a lot of the decisions
we make sort of very fundamentally shape
shapes organize
you may use the word company that month
got often so it's kind of hard to IPO
that kind of the I peel the I peel
doesn't really fit our type of
organization which is totally which is
very decentralized and I also don't
believe in the IPO game I think that
games really way the system really
broken basically the entrepreneurs are
no longer number one the entrepreneurs
are no longer making the money that they
basically have to yield to this is very
early on to be able to grow a large
platform because two core a platform you
do need to have it you do need heavy
investments and typically entrepreneurs
have the skills may or may not have the
skills but they don't have the money and
when the institutional investors come in
when the VCS come in they want returns
that they like to be honest very few
VC's care about their vision most guys
will care about the vision would be
building stuff themselves there's very
few that do care about the visions I
don't want to like I don't want to like
often everybody but but most mostly VCS
have a have a fun to have a like a
fixed-term show returns they need to run
that they need to raise the next fund
etc and they naturally want to have
pressure to sort of cash out and they
want to earn the firm's to IPO and then
when the firm's IPO the BC the CEOs are
typically keeping a mandate you get the
price to a certain point and they
usually have a deal
and then the CEOs get a bonus when they
get to that point the VC's cash out at
that point and then the retails the you
tell you nesters get left holding in the
bag and hopefully if the company does
well within the future great but there's
a lot of risks there but everybody knows
how to play that game so that this is
why the CEOs gets a lot of money this is
why the VCS structure the deal stay away
I don't think super beneficial I think
there's a better structure that can be
achieved we have a lot more freedom we
are we are luckily we are we are
cashflow positive and we can dictate our
own growth at the rate we grow at we can
from relatively new ideas sometimes some
really wild ideas so we're kind of
operating as a start-up but also
investment arm and we have
a lot of experiments going on so we have
a lot of freedom to try this kind of
stuff and we have a very United team so
we don't we don't have a board telling
us what to do etc so so I think yeah I
don't I don't see the need to do IPO and
also given the regulatory uncertainty in
many jurisdictions it's still unclear to
see how a crypto currency exchanges
gonna IPO so we prefer to let probably
less somebody else do that first and we
we don't we don't need to be the first
one there yeah
that brings up B & B which I think
there's a lot of folks you know thing
will take point but you know what these
people have kind of written these long
analysis on the idea that b and b if you
don't go the IPO route can serve as a
way to really drive kind of shareholder
value but in this unique new model maybe
talk a little bit about where B & B is
today and then kind of how you see that
evolving over time sure I think we
structured B & B is very much a bit
illicit token so it does not represent
security in - not being balanced or any
of the - affiliated entities
it's a freely traded coin that we used
to we used to we use the ICO back in
2017 to raise some funds to bootstrap
the platform and then from there I think
today is growing about 130 X from in the
last two years and the peak is growing
about 400 X but you know there's
fluctuations and there's this common
discussion between what's the difference
between shares and they talk so now
that's a pretty interesting dynamic so I
think the shares and tokens could be
separate but especially if you want to
if they said look the tokens are used in
the ecosystem for like let's not use my
finance let's use like say a gaming
company right so you issue a token
people can use used it to pay for I
don't know can eat virtual merchandise
like so then you use that in the game
and then you have the company shares
that you can stalk the company shares
are worth however much you can look at
the income profit etc of the company and
determine the price of that where we
have chosen not to well at least for now
we're not you sort of monetize the
shares aspects of Finance so the
and right now so we don't we don't see a
need for it right now and a lot of
companies stay private even like if you
look at Bloomberg Bloomberg company is
still private it's a valuable company
but Bloomberg makes money from profits
so he didn't really sell a lot of shares
to make money so I think right now our
focus really just and I think right now
if we say we launch my way issue like -
shares and raise a lot of money and
continue to do that you actually dilute
some of the value in the B&B ecosystem
so we actually just want to say look we
will continue to push B and B to be used
anymore cause you know ecosystem and
also you are at partners ecosystems and
that's what we're gonna be focused on
and we're not gonna we so I'm at least
right now I'm not really thinking about
monetizing the shares at all actually I
would I haven't I have an idea which I
don't talk to people asking about I
eventually want to make - a real deal
like a real decentralized autonomous
operation and if we do that then we warm
the consider once the things we will
have to do is we will likely have to
forego the valuable shares so okay so
you got to explain you gotta explain
this a little bit because this is I
think kind of the extreme end of the non
IPO path which is you essentially
decentralize the entire thing and you
being the founder it's a big financial
decision because you basically would say
the equity in what I've built is going
to be worth zero you're not gonna have
the payday from the equity and you now
have this Dow but if you have the cash
flow there's obviously value there maybe
talk through exactly like what would
that world look like and then what would
that mean for you and the rest of the
team sure I actually don't know what
that word would look like to be honest
we kind of this is new territory so we
can expect experimenting ourselves and
so we're kind of working territory we
just landed on this land and we're still
exploring we we can see there's a forest
we don't know what's in the forest we
can see there's a hill we don't know
what's behind it kind of thing so in my
mind we'll turn up in that territory in
terms of organizational structure etc we
do have team members who have SOPs we do
have
we still do have a couple external
shareholders and so and so this aspect
is it is a it is an interesting topic to
sort of explore and discuss but I do
think a company who has very well okay I
would like yeah I would say organization
who have very strong cash flow are able
to take care of their employees
shareholders etc so the different ways
to monetize and this is why I steam to
the long term play that that we have I
mean you can say or shares and well
basically the shares encompass future
value right so the the value of the
shares of a company encompass how much
money can be made later on where if you
just do a dividend or profit split to
two people and it's just how much money
we've earned so far but if you but if
you take a longer version say look the
ich there there are many companies who
does not who does not go IPO that many
founders who liked it again taking
Bloomberg for example like and the guys
really rich and he has hey I think he
still owns 70% of the shares of the
company and the never release or their
name anything else Merrill Lynch was
well mom they investors probably still
yes well the probably change hands
because Merrill may have may have had
its own financial issues but so in that
in that aspect I think there's I think
as long as you get investors and you get
team members will eat into the same
vision we're here for the long term play
then that's less of a problem we
actually looked at a new idea that which
I think we invented actually so I named
it
and so I named it and then a our team
kind of is polishing it we call eg okie
so instead an employee stock option we
call it employee token options we
actually don't like the word employee we
call them team members but in WTOP it's
kind of cheesy but overall though we
want to say look of our profits we can
distribute some to inc tokens to our
team members and the tokens are
interesting because the tokens value
fluctuates with how well the ecosystems
doing and and if
this way the team members say
incentivize to sort of cool the
ecosystem not just a corporate value not
just like nothing did not just an
enterprise value but more of these sort
of echo system and I think that that's
much that's actually more aligned with
what we want to achieve right now we
want to build good out of the ecosystem
and want to centralize sort of the the
the enterprise aspect of it even though
right now
I think banners calm especially the
trading platforms do is a large revenue
generator but things could check like we
have a text it's not a super big right
now but if okay thanks for changing
three years five years so weeks we are
experimenting with that and I think
super fascinating and but if you if you
ask me like look what's the blueprint is
100% gonna go this way
I don't really know to be honest because
it's over the territory we're
experimenting and we may make some
mistakes and we have to readjust but
where we are exploring with the team
together so and I think whatever we
wherever we find out that works we will
be very happy to share with the
community and hopefully other
organizations will be able to follow -
unique yeah - is unique in this ways we
actually started as more centralized
organization which pushing this way
whereas other like projects like
aetherium they did start much more
decentralized so it's a bit different
yeah